all right elizabeth
yeah elizabeth um you grew up in tulsa
you told me
yeah yeah tulsa oh oklahoma and uh
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up yeah
how was your childhood how was your wife
how was your childhood
childhood okay very well something like
little house on the prairie i don't know
really yeah
something like like that that's nice
and uh you grew up with uh
other siblings yeah yeah kane mercy
and stacy and tracy that's all i
as far as i remember you left home at
what age
oh about 18 after high school
yeah and where'd you go oh just went on
and
went to school or something you know
call home high school
further past that oh in california yeah
so you guys moved to california
yeah but they never went to college no
not yet
they wanted did you have that do you
have children yeah yeah
six kids six kids yeah and you raised
them
yeah yeah they're all fine they're
beautiful and you're
they're healthy and you're happy they
never complained
and never complained or anything and you
did so you're living on the street here
yeah downtown l.a this is the city you
lost in
yeah and uh did you live in a tent or
where do you stay
wherever with friends and family and and
things like that and then go over there
and make a living and no clean up
good jobs jobs or something
uh you know vacuuming cleaning these
kind of things
and just wasn't sure what it was good
good lessons
of the past and
things like that are good for your brain
you know i
jogging and exercise every day but when
i wake up in the morning the main thing
is i look just saying
give her out there nope do you uh
my aunt probably put that when she was a
nurse and stuff
because she looked like that she had
beautiful eyes wouldn't you
do you still have contact with your kids
oh yeah yeah yeah they're fine you're
fine
with jose my husband sir yeah when i see
them yeah i don't have no problems with
that that's just the way they were born
how do you do you have a phone uh yeah
and rancho cucamonga
and nj no but did you do you have a cell
phone to call your children
myself do you have a phone to call your
children uh
just the wednesday handed me uh back
over there where i was at but no
no no that's okay that's fine yeah just
a little
the different ones that i didn't know
how to work them because i wasn't sure
whatever do your kids know
but i learned to help real quick do your
kids know that you're here on the street
yeah yeah they know i'm a good mother
you know
my my kids were a little bit smarter
than me
though too again like like a turtle
but why do i say that oh and you know i
saw turtle like
in riverside or something there but it
was more poster guys
that's a nice movie do you have
any problems living on the street no no
no nobody has you no
no and nobody no bad mouthing nobody and
nobody gave me
harassment not even gossip use words
like that
like zackenberg the school teacher
here's the new york school teacher you
know
but about that big yeah he was from
jay high school you know the brown book
where you study history
yeah that's how i made my skin in my
body you uh
do you use any of the drugs that are out
here no no maybe
something to kill pain sure yeah anybody
would
but i was never obnoxious with it no no
alcohol or drugs
no no no no well las vegas you couldn't
help yourself
yeah but they never took advantage of
that because they could
but they they couldn't even get it if
they tried
they would try to you know get that out
in the
open so you know take it out on somebody
you know some
some people are like that for me how
many years have you lived on the street
oh since they've been here in los
angeles
well uh probably like
two plus one like three years i've been
here now i think
shelter what were we doing before that
well nothing just
married and had kids and didn't work at
you know restaurants they had a good job
and
you made very much money but that was
enough but what would you learn
what happened to you that you ended up
homeless oh it just just the way it was
just lucky like that probably
my family was like that in the past i
couldn't figure out how they
did that so that's why
pandora she always my cousin she she was
always
you know a little uh faster
than me i was too slow you know you
could take it it works take it out of me
you know that's the way it was in the
past
and do you have parents still or uh yeah
yeah you're still happy t.w and jan
that's
what i called when i saw a picture of
them though you know the other day in
los angeles
they were wondering where they've been
all these years oh they live in jay
oklahoma
you know somewhere out in the country
that's where they live i didn't choose
that for me
that that was their favorite place to be
but when's last time
when's the last time you spoke to your
family um
oh jay oh
[Music]
gosh that was uh i'm not sure what year
that was because i've been you know
sleeping
um i sleep a lot and do
daily things but i always wake up
looking uh when's the last time i talked
to
my parents and jay oh let's see she
worked down there slightly
about 10 years ago something like that
where do you eat oh just when my
mother's
the where do you eat now
oh we're right now yeah they shelter
mostly with my friends and family
it's all the extent yeah together do you
have any
do you have any friends here on the
street well it's not strangers no
no not that i know they thought of
others but he did
never you know
never i always go back to people that
were good to me because that
that's just the way it is but i
remember when i was in school i i
graduated 12th grade at central high
school tulsa
all my my friends he was a real nice
uh friend he'd you know sit by me or
listen that or whatever i couldn't
remember exactly
what he was thinking but he he was right
about a lot of things she did
something out there but yeah it is nice
in los
angeles because they bring bring back
the
happy things you know but what was the
happiest point of your life
oh getting the high school diploma and
five times you got that
uh at the eighth grade and
the san bernardino high school and then
uh i find another this in that school
high school plus the other
uh school in los angeles i didn't know
that was there i was so
surprised i couldn't believe it it was
so
lucky to have school anyways because
they were so
into that
you ever been treated for any like
mental conditions or anything like that
yeah i'm schizophrenia doctor selector
and i can't yeah i do i
already had that uh
insert in my body and i didn't know what
to do with
and he knows it and do you take the
medications
yeah take a lot especially when it's
looking right at you
are you are you taking them now um
no just a little bit of pills i take but
i never
take uh od or anything
because i'm not like that nobody you
can't make
living on the street i'm guessing that
maybe you're not taking your medications
oh yeah yeah i take some pills
pain or things that control your
mind just like exercise every day
but if you don't want to eat or you're
full full full then you get skinny again
but
it all depends upon how you looked at it
when you saw it on your lap
but i don't know what
elizabeth thank you thank you for
talking with me you're welcome
and i wish you the best of luck living
on the street like this
yeah yeah there is something
it seems like you should probably be
taken care of somehow in something yeah
yeah just looking at myself
in that something and the body
was last time
when's the last time you took a shower
oh when uh my mascara
uh oh when i took your shirt when was
the last time you took a shower
over there by 7-eleven
yeah it's a place i take a shower around
6th street
get showers the cold ones but when's the
last time you took one
oh about two or three days ago
yeah i'm fine it's so beautiful but i
always
you know find these beautiful things i
couldn't believe it down
i said it was i just think my god he
gave me all these things
i didn't even know that didn't know
all right elizabeth thank you so much
thank you for talking with me
you